so that takes us up until right now
with star trek discovery and season
three started two weeks ago one week ago
it's
two episodes of air now yeah so last
night was that was the second one
and there's a huge change the show has
has blasted off into the future
i wonder what you're you know because
they were so entrenched in one timeline
for two seasons i'm wondering what your
reaction is to be the show is gonna be
massively changed as season three starts
yeah yeah well we you know massively
changed we we're boldly doing
going where no star trek series has gone
before and that was a permanent jump to
the future
um 930 years so
not just a couple years we went to a
whole new era
with a new set of rules new new worlds
and new
customs new everything what this did for
the writers though
we were playing ten years before the
original series in the first two seasons
now we've jumped way ahead of all of the
series so we're
so we started we started having to
adhere to canon
and to make sure that that everything
that we were doing didn't didn't affect
later later series and decisions and and
and uh canon and storyline that they
were already that have already been
filmed and already played
we had to fit in with that now they've
jumped ahead to where the writers have
freedom to
create from the ground up now uh so
so that's exciting that's exciting and
and you know we'll we'll explore
new worlds and new creatures and um uh a
new
um and and of course
the nostalgia of of all the species that
you know already
we're going to visit them again but they
might have different relationships with
each other than
you what you know so it's all it's all
exciting to see
how the universe how the galaxy had
changed in those 930 years
yeah is there a sense that that this
this major change is sort of
how it's sort of how it bodes for the
future of the show in general they sort
of
like is this change gonna be permanent
and does this
sort of open up the idea that the show
will continue to evolve as it goes on we
have season to season even
episode episodes and stuff like that
because it is interesting to me that
season one and season two are what they
are and then the show was like
boom we're changing things and i'm
wondering how that goes to the future of
the show
yeah again those decisions are above my
my pay grade yeah that's that's the the
show runners and the writers are are the
ones who
um are keeping it very fresh that way um
you know we're unlike other to other
star trek series in the past
in that we um for a couple reasons
really uh it seems like we're we're more
um overall arc story
minded for the binge watcher as opposed
to the bottle episode
start middle and end in each episode
there's
much more of an open overarching uh
story that you that you follow from week
to week
um the other thing has been that our
captain's chair has been a musical chair
we've had different butts in it you know
and um
and the lead of our show is not the
captain the lead of our show has been
uh michael burnham played by sneaker
martin green then you're following her
path from
she starts as a first officer commits
mutiny
goes uh gets it gets a set back and then
we we're watching her climb
through the ranks again so that's all
that's all kind of unique and new
uh so this jump to the future kind of
fits in that whole unique new
let's let's do something daring and
different with this series uh
model that they've they've made for us
and it's it's all it's been working uh
you know
uh by and large has been working so i i
think i think that bodes well
i don't know who knows how many seasons
we have in us i don't know
uh and what will they do to make each
one bring that new fresh
unique twist to it i have no idea that's
again
i i'm glad we have writers for that not
me exactly but but you specifically your
character
is taking on much more of a leadership
role and it's interesting because i i
feel like the physicality you've brought
a different physicality
to the character as the characters
change and i'm wondering what this
big change in season three has meant for
your performance uh specific
in season two you saw
that's where i went through my change
where i was living in fear with threat
gangly that would spring out of my neck
every so often
uh and now that's gone i've gone through
a change called vahreh where
you know we used to think that was the
end of our lives and that's actually
just
uh puberty basically we're going into
our adolescence now and
i i have hundreds of years left to live
so with that uh that that was a surprise
to me when the writers
when i got that episode i thought oh are
they killing me off no they're not
killing me off they're
oh this is a big change because i had
patterned and
and ingested this character into my soul
uh
as a fear-driven species and now that
that
innate fear is gone it did change some
things it did change
um his decision making and his posturing
and uh and how he interacts with other
other crew members and
and uh whatnot it has it's a bit bolder
a bit more decisive um and uh and so
he's
not no that all happened in season two
now that we jump into season three
uh he has to continue that uh his
confidence has to remain intact because
he
right now is the acting captain um he
was first
officer uh under under the tutelage of
uh of captain pike in season two
who was borrowed from from the starship
enterprise
at the end of season two he goes back to
the enterprise and we're left with an
empty captain's chair again
so uh as first officer of course that's
i i step into that as acting captain for
temporarily but we had a huge task ahead
of us when that happened we were now
jumping through a wormhole
in time to up to the future and
the so the question remains and and
episodes one and two did not answer this
yet so this is yet to come
what's going to happen to our captain's
chair permanently we don't know
um because it was decided that like uh
that
surrew my character and cindy and uh
michael burnham we kind of shared a
glance across the bridge and
and when captain pike was saying we have
to decide about the captain's chair
and i said let's get through this time
jump first then we can discuss the
captaincy
so the uh and i threw it through a look
to burn them she threw a look back to me
so it's an understanding the two of us
are probably
equally well qualified for it uh equally
desirous of it
but equally um also desirous that the
other person get it
because we've our relationship has grown
and gotten so close and so brotherly
sisterly
that we really do appreciate and respect
each other so much
uh that i i want that that position for
her as much as she wants it for me
so that's yet to be decided so now that
we're now that we've jumped through the
wormhole
the other question remains uh are we
going to find the federation
a are we going to find them b if we do
what condition will they be in will they
be
in a state of disrepair will they be up
and running will they want to assign us
a captain of
of their own from the future that
understands the world we're in now
better
or do we have to self-govern that and
assign a captain
amongst ourselves so that's still also
yet to be
decided now but in episode one
uh uh it was shown that like the
federation has kind of been missing
uh if they're out there they're they're
well hidden so for the time so we will
need to
probably it's not so it probably will
have to come down to michael burnham and
suru deciding among ourselves so that's
yet to be
uh yet to be explored stay tuned for
that so stay tuned for sure yeah
um correct me if i'm wrong but this was
a surprise to a lot of people season
four was not only confirmed but it's
shooting in a week you start filming
november 2nd yeah
incredible uh obviously you can't tell
me much about it because
we're right in the center of season
three obviously right but i'm just
wondering you know
was there that same sense of uh when you
when you were told
how deep into the however much you know
about the future of the show was there
that same sense of surprise was that
that same sense of again the show not
not not
specifically reinventing itself but just
like oh wow the show is continuing
like you said to go boldly into into new
space
yeah well you know it seemed to me like
the old days of television a show would
not announce a renewal for the next
season until the
the current season was either halfway
done or almost done or
well done uh so for us to
you know to have to have be prepping and
announcing
a a new season because we
we knew that it was going to be filming
long before it started season three
started airing
so uh so i guess um i don't know what
again those decisions are above my pay
grade and i don't know
what goes into making that decision what
you know how they decide it
shows profitability when they haven't
really tested the season that's current
yet
i don't know i don't know how that how
that works um i'm just i'm just grateful
that it that uh that they just that they
have the faith in us that the network
has the faith in us
and that the fan base has stuck with us
to to uh
you know to warrant that kind of faith